alright last topic and this gets back to
replay review for pass interference
Chris I don't know if you saw the play
from the Rams cowboys game late in the
fourth quarter Saturday night there was
a ruling on the field of no pass
interference by offense or defense Shawn
McVeigh the Rams head coach threw the
flag and the end result was a phantom
defensive pass interference penalty
after nearly four minutes of review
presided over by al Riverrun some 5,000
miles away from Hawaii now regardless of
how we feel about our verone's ability
to properly in real-time under that
pressure of do it now do it now and I
think all of us would make mistakes when
expected to make a rational reliable
correct decision in that moment where we
feel like everyone's watching us and
everyone is is doing this and singing
the jeopardy music it's not easy to do
but be that as it may
right now Chris had dawned on me
recently al Riverrun is the most
powerful person in football during the
playing of games because the only person
who can for every game grant or take
away gigantic chunks of field position
based upon pass interference calls and
non calls specifically defensive or he
can wipe out a 50-yard gain because he
can say there was offensive pass
interference I mean this guy has almost
a God power over the NFL games
especially as it relates to pass
interference calls and non calls and I
don't know that it's good for the NFL to
have one person having that much power
over it's it's on-field rules
application yeah let's start there how
is he gonna do all this how is it really
like I really do I worry about this you
know there's eight games in one o'clock
when week one and you know there's
there's two other two other replay
reviews going on and all of a sudden two
other other games pass interference is
getting reviewed I mean I don't know I
just don't know how it's gonna work this
review you're talking about in the
Dallas Rams game you mentioned it it
took four minutes I mean holy cow what's
he gonna do if there's four other place
that need to be replay reviewed during a
complicated type play like we saw in the
Dallas Los Angeles scenario worse
the unintended consequences too here a
little bit already - with a legal
contact and pass interference
who was the ball in the air or not
because illegal contact is when the
quarterback still has the ball
that's not reviewable this is gonna piss
fans off too because they're gonna see a
legal contact on plays now and and then
a coach might think from the size I know
that was a you know that was passing
their fear ins and then in super slow
motion we're gonna look at it the ball
might still be in the quarterbacks hand
and now the unintended consequence might
be oh actually your own team the guy
that's challenging your own team had
passed interference when the ball was in
the air so no you challenge the thinking
you were gonna win something and in fact
you're gonna lose it now I think it's
gonna make like coaches kind of be
careful a little bit about how often
they throw this flag to a degree to to
make sure they see the totality of some
of these plays but yeah I'm not liking
this so far I just fired off an email to
Michael Senora of the NFL to find out
and it's more of a refresher there are
these little things that I learn about
and then you forget about them and then
you have to relearn them there are other
people in the room who will step in to
handle replay review if foul reveron is
busy with one game but you're then
you're transferring that that godpower -
right yeah and and and and it's always
been one of the concerns when it comes
to replay review at 3:45 Park Avenue and
I think it takes on an even greater
importance when we begin reviewing
subjective decisions again and I'm gonna
keep saying this every time the
opportunity arises Chris there's a huge
difference between did the guy get two
feet inbounds before he stepped out with
possession of the ball was his knee down
before the ball came out those are
things that we can look at and say
objectively yes or no what happened this
whole idea of clear and obvious evidence
of significant hindrance to the receiver
that is inherently subjective and you
slow it down you frame by frame and I
don't know what the hell they're seeing
and for some of these calls we've seen
and the one on Saturday night was the
most glaring I don't know how you call
the Cowboys defensive back for pass
interference on a 10-yard curl route
where the Rams receiver ran to the top
of the route and shoved the defensive
back to engage him so he could turn
around and get separation
and the defensive back joined in that
push and then the defensive back gets
flagged for your replay grab this very
right and most of the contact happen
before the ball was even thrown like
you're saying contact before the ball is
thrown right so I I just I really am
concerned and and I really do think a
lot of it comes down to the ability of
our River on or anyone and maybe the
answer is no one can do this when you
feel all that pressure you know the
anxiety the needles on the back of your
neck and and if people standing around
you and you got to make the decision
quickly and what do I really see here
and how am I gonna and how many times do
I have to look at it I mean it was three
minutes and 40 seconds from the end of
the play to the moment the referee John
Hussey began to explain what the ruling
was that's an unacceptable delay if it
should take that long it should never be
overturned right so just sir would you
feel better if like just I'm throwing
for instance out there but I mean I
would feel better if I knew okay
Alvar River runs back there who I know
Al's got a tough job I know we're being
tough right here but listen now we know
this is the real deal Holyfield but
could you he got thrust into a job that
wasn't designed for Dean blandina so as
I say would you feel better this is
where maybe the NFL needs to address
this or go down here instead of just
having one King let's have three kings I
mean I would feel better if it was our
River on Mike Pereira and Dean Blandino
in the room I really would I would go
okay here's three really smart football
guys who understand the rules and now
maybe they can come to a consensus and
maybe that would take some of the doubt
out of all of us to to just go okay
here's three reasonable human beings who
saw this way
I mean maybe something like that because
portal isn't a really tough no-win
situation right now where I mean my head
would be popping off I think if I had a
deal with officiating week one or a
normal week in the NFL what they need to
do and and I know that this is gonna
require the the swallowing of some pride
the suppression of some ego and the
expenditure of some money that the NFL
would rather not spend they need to call
Dean Blandino and they need to offer him
between five and ten million dollars a
year to come back and take that job over
there period that's what they need to do
that's over
we won 3% of that now that we're asking
for 5 or 10 for you 3%
I want 10% baby no Dean come to me he'll
give me 3 probably give more creeper
said you'll get your money's worth Dean
get your money's worth baby all right
but that's what they need to do and look
I'm trying to be fair to Alan trying to
be fair to the NFL yeah they they don't
value the position Dean Blandino has
told me that that is a very diplomatic
way of saying they're cheap yeah and
it's amazing how much money they have
and how many ways they will spend the
money but on certain things they won't
and and this is now the most important
and powerful job in the NFL it's more
powerful than the commissioner
dan I'd rather have the commissioner
handle the pass interference replay
reviews at least he's getting paid the
money to deal with the pressure say I
feel bad for al yeah I mean think about
how this wears on you and the dread
could you imagine every Saturday night
when our everyone goes to bed nice
thinking oh god what's gonna happen
tomorrow during the 12 hours that
probably goes Baron and and wait for the
next fire right am I gonna get it right
am I gonna get it wrong and what are
buttholes like Florio gonna say about me
the next day I wouldn't want that job
though I mean gosh think how about he
must feel for me I got a deal with your
butt Holness every day
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports